the American astronaut who survived a
dramatic failure of a Russian rocket
says he's lucky the emergency abort
system worked sure is
astronaut Nick Hague was one of two
people in the capsule when something
went wrong plunging them back down to
earth this was the first launch abort of
the normally reliable Soyuz rocket in 35
years the mishap grounded the program
indefinitely it is the only way for us
astronauts to get to space tonita copal
is here with how Hague described the
emergency landing
Tonie good morning good morning Hague is
a former Air Force test pilot which
means he's had some close calls before
but nothing quite like this
he'd been training for the mission to
the space station for the past two years
his wife and children were there to
watch what was supposed to be his first
trip into space things did not go as
planned
I imagined that my first trip to outer
space was going to be a memorable one I
didn't expect it to be quite this
memorable astronaut Nick Hague and
cosmonaut Alexei of Chinon were two
minutes into their climb to orbit
traveling at four times the speed of
sound when their Soyuz rocket failed it
went from normal to something was wrong
pretty quick a strap-on booster
apparently crashed into the side of the
rocket central booster and burst into a
cloud of debris the automatic abort
system detected trouble and threw the
cruise capsule up and away
the first thing I really noticed was
being shaken fairly violently side to
side as that safety system pulled us
away from the rocket you're a little bit
startled and then I saw the booster
failure light inside the capsule and at
that point you know I realized hey we're
not gonna make it to orbit today and you
just your training kicks in and you're
ready to respond and so Alexa and I
changed gears a crew member aboard the
space station caught the moment on
camera if you look closely you can see
the Soyuz capsule nearly reaching the
edge of space before gravity pulled it
back down to earth there was a point
where I looked out the window and I saw
the curve of the earth out there and
that in the blackness of space and it
was bittersweet you know fleeting moment
knowing that I got that close you know
what can you do sometimes you don't get
a vote
Haga novena ended safely in Kazakhstan
about 250 miles from the launch site
there the crewmates hung upside down in
their capsule waiting for help we looked
at each other we had grins from ears two
ears he holds out a hand I shake his
hand and and then we start you know
cracking a few jokes between us about
how how short our flight was the two
were treated to a snack and a medical
check-up before being reunited with
their families including Haig's wife
Katie I got to tell you that when we
finally got to hug each other coming
down off the plane it was a bit of
release for both of us the emotions that
we've been kind of holding back just to
stay focused on the situation as for the
boys my youngest god bless him he looks
at me and he goes dad when are you going
back to space well on that point the
Russians are investigating trying to
find out exactly what went wrong Hague
says he wants to go back again but he's
not sure when he'll get another chance
maybe just next year he also said that
after he landed he stood outside the
capsule and tried to call his wife on a
satellite phone but the call went to
voicemail I left her a message saying it
had one wild ride not much luck with
technology for him that day I loved his
son's reaction when he going back to
space and this guy he's so calm and so
focused I like what he says goes from
normal to something wrong very quickly
and sometimes you don't get a vote when
they came crashing down they were
speaking in Russian because he has to
speak so imagine you're getting new
tousle inside out in Russian yeah he's
amazing
we're Air Force test pilot those guys
know what they're doing well that's yeah
come to me for some Russian lessons next
time thank you